oh my goodness as a property investor
and with a property Channel I am so
excited to talk about 100 mortgages
because they are back in the UK the
first time since
2008. this is huge Skipton mortgages
skipped and mortgages were the first
lender that introduced by to let
mortgages and now they have finally
brought in 100 mortgages for first-time
buyers huge one of the reasons I'm so
excited about this because when I
started in 2008 everyone's everyone says
oh it was easy for you because you could
get 100 mortgages I mean they scrapped
it just after I got started but still
and that was what how many years ago 14
years ago now they're back no excuses so
in this video I'm going to talk about
what 100 mortgages are specific
requirements of Skipton mortgage and
whether you are eligible or not maybe
right now you're renting if you're
renting and you're paying a grand a
month do you know that you could
potentially buy the house that you're
renting
with 100 mortgage without putting down a
penny as a deposit this is crazy how do
I think it's going to affect the housing
market in the UK over the coming months
and years and do I think this is a good
thing a bad thing and should you be
doing it so if you enjoy my channel do
me a favor smash the like button and I
want to know your thoughts as well in
the comments below so 100 mortgages what
does it mean 100 mortgage simply means
that when you're buying a house there'll
be a lender that will give you a hundred
percent of the money to buy the house
okay normally speaking when you buy a
house you might put down a deposit right
so if you want to buy a house for 300
000 pounds and let's say you need to put
down 20 because every different lender
has got a different requirement of how
much you need to put as a deposit
compared to how much they're going to
loan you so if you're buying a house for
300 000 pounds and you can speak to a
bank or you speak to a mortgage lender
and they say oh you need to put down 20
then that means that you need to save up
sixty thousand pounds
and you'll put down sixty thousand and
sometimes the lenders on top of that
will charge you a fee
just for giving you the money they'll
say you need to put down sixty thousand
we'll loan you the rest and you need to
pay us a fee for giving you the loan
skip to mortgages have said for certain
people and this is for first-time buyers
that want to buy the house that they are
living in now of course you can't do
this if you've got terrible credit you
also have to have been renting the
property for the last 12 months and
there's of course affordability checks
if you're living in a house I think I
think it's up to 600 and something
thousand pounds is the maximum amount
and it also depends on how much rent
you're paying right now so if you're
paying a ground which is about the
average rent to own a thousand pounds
they will loan you up to 163
000 pounds so you know this you can't be
buying a mansion on 100 mortgage this is
for first-time buyers this is for uh not
for brand new apartments and this is for
tenants who are wanting to buy a house
without using the deposit another great
thing about this is Skip tools don't
charge a fee so there's no fee so the
only thing that you're going to have to
pay if you're eligible for this and you
live in a house that you want to buy is
your legal Feast your solicitor fees
which might cost you about a thousand
pounds so that's what it is do I think
it's a good thing and how do I think
it's going to affect the the housing
market I think it's a great thing I
think it's a really really good
opportunity for first-time buyers to get
on the property ladder and I think that
ultimately
if you look at Working Class People okay
normal average Everyday People in nine
to five jobs that don't make more than
50 60 Grand a year if you look over
their life
from the age of 20 to 60. most
working-class people make made most of
their money not in their job you know
what you know how most people make money
accidentally accidentally they've been
trying
through the house that they buy most
people work their ass off for 40 years
working 40 hours a week and how much
they're making like 20 30 grand and
they're having to spend all that to live
if you look at the average person speaks
the average 50 or 60 or 70 year old most
of the money that I made was accidental
wealth made by buying a house and the
problem is with today in 2023 is if you
need 60 000 pounds to buy a house How
Are You Gonna Save 60 000 pounds saving
up sixty thousand pounds is going to
take you a lifetime so for the average
person to get on the property ladder it
is a nightmare so I think 100 mortgages
are a fantastic thing I think it's going
to help Ordinary People tenants get on
the property ladder what are some of the
cons well it's possible that you might
buy a house for say a hundred grand and
you get 100 mortgage you buy a house and
it's possible that that house drops in
value what does that mean that means
that you are now in negative equity so
there is a possibility of debt when I
bought my first house in 2009 for a
hundred thousand pounds it dropped in
value I bought in 2009 and everyone was
saying what are you doing and it dropped
in value but I didn't sell it I held on
to it and now it's worth 300 000 pounds
I still own it today so short time if
houses drop you may be in negative
equity however does that really matter
because if you're planning on living in
the house forever or for a long time if
you hold on to it long enough it's gonna
probably go up in value the security
you'll get from I only get I think it's
a good thing the other thing I'll
mention as well is the interest rate
that skips the charging is just over I
think it's 5.3 percent it's just over
five percent so if you're borrowing 100
Grand that means that you're gonna
you're gonna need to work out how much
are you having to be paying on interest
and make sure that that amount is less
than rent okay because there's no point
buying a house living in it getting 100
mortgage if you then can't afford to pay
the interest payments so I think
generally it's a really good thing what
I will say is this though even smarter
than buying a house and getting 100 of
the money from skip to mortgages
would be to do this because let's put
this into perspective the house you're
buying from Skipton
the mortgage requirement is going to
have certainties and seats so for
example I don't I'm not um I'm not
eligible for skip to mortgage but I
imagine you probably can't get a skipped
and mortgage 100 and then rent it out
you have to live in it yourself
I don't know if you can rent the rooms
out maybe you can maybe you can't but
there's going to be limitations so I
would say is if you're excited about the
idea of getting a house without putting
down a deposit it
even if you don't qualify for skip to do
it you can do instead you can find a
house
a really good investment property that
you've negotiated by cheap and you get
100 loan to buy it not from Skipton but
from an investor you can go to property
investment networking events and find
investors that are time poor and cash
rich and you can say hey I found a
banging deal
and I want you to put the money in
and I will do all the work and we'll
split the money so there's more than one
way to get a house without putting down
a deposit the description mortgages so
what I would say is whilst I think this
is a really good thing be open-minded to
other ways you can get a house without
pointing deposit down on a purchase
lease option agreement
I thought this is one of the things I
did when I was 19 years old I bought a
house my first lease option agreement it
was on the market for 85 Grand
there was no equity in it the seller was
motivated and I said
what's the lowest you could accept he
said 81.
I said well I'll buy it for 81. but I'll
buy it in seven years time
and in the meantime I'll take over the
mortgage payments so I took over the
mortgage payments of 145 pound a month
rented it out for 550 made a little
income from it
and then used that extra income that I
was making saved it as a deposit and
then in seven years time I had the
option to buy for 81 and in which point
it was worth way more than 81. I mean
damn you could even control properties
on rent to rent without putting down a
deposit
so there's so many ways that you can buy
properties without a deposit but this is
just one Skipton maybe you're eligible
if you're eligible if you're living in a
house
and you're a tenant and you like it
and the landlord's up for selling
and you qualify with Skipton boom good
go do it get on the property ladder buy
it hold on to it have the security of it
cool but if you don't qualify and you're
not eligible then go and get a purchase
lease option agreement or go and find an
investor or an angel investor buy a
property cheap that's run down and get a
bridging loan there are bridging
companies that will give you a hundred
percent sometimes if the deal is good
enough that doesn't make the headlines
though does it 100 bridging man buy it
cheap push the value up and then
refinance it pay off the bridging line
you left with the house with Freight has
so many ways so I love the scripting
thing
um it could potentially push house
watches up a little bit I think it's
going to out balance things um I don't
think it's going to massively affect the
property Market because I don't think
enough people will do it I think that a
lot of people won't be eligible and
those that are eligible probably just
not even know it exists all but like oh
I can't afford the legal fees it's
amazing people say that you know I met a
lady recently who said she had the right
to buy her house it was a council house
and she had the right to buy it 60 below
market value imagine that 60 below
market value and not only that okay
because she said but it doesn't matter
it could be 70 I don't have the money to
buy it I put her in touch with a
mortgage broker who said that she could
use the discount as the deposit she
could put down
all she had to pay was a legal Feast of
2000 maps and she could buy the house in
London sixty percent below architecture
because I haven't got any legal fees
there I can't afford to pay the legal
fees I was so
like angry
I just gave her the 2 000 pounds
because it's like come on if you so a
lot of people won't do this
um I don't think it's going to massively
affect the housing market it might be
that more and more people stop doing it
if they do start doing 100 mortgages I
mean if we look back at history in 2008
when the banks were given out 125
mortgages I mean I remember when the
banks were literally oh I want to buy
this house for 100 grand here's 125
Grand 100 grand for the house and 25
Grand to refurb it and have a holiday
that's how crazy the banks were they got
so loose and giving out money that house
prices went right up because everyone's
buying houses if everyone's buying
houses everyone's got the money to buy a
house who does push house prices up then
the banks run out of money suddenly we
had the credit crunch then houses
crashed the outages would always go up
down up down but uh ultimately houses
are a good asset if you could hold on to
them
um so that's my thoughts what do you
think though comment below if you want
to do some of the other strategies like
if you want to do um you know purchase
lease option agreements or you want to
do deal sourcing where you want to raise
finance and find buy refurbish refinance
auction opportunities anything like this
I'd love to spend a day with you and
teach you at the property investors
crash course all I know about property
condensed into one day thousands of
people have done this one pound course
and thousands of people have results so
if you want to come and spend a day with
me I'll leave a link in the description
get booked on and I wish you all the
very best in your success
[Music]
foreign